hello everyone welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the 1914
Tournament of Sun picture book and the
Capablanca faces a very strong Hungarian
chess master Isadora Ginsberg and
Ginsberg had a very very long Chester
year behind him at the moment here in
1914 he's 60 years old and he started
his just career actually pretending to
be a chess automaton the so called
Mephisto it's similar to the Turk I
don't know if all of you know what the
Turk was the the so-called mechanical
automaton that played chess even though
you know it was a hoax there was
actually a person hiding inside it here
you can see that this is a reconstructed
Turk from the 1980s as the real Turk was
ruined in a fire in 1954 and sorry in
1854 and after that you know it would
just burn down and this is basically
what it looked like to my knowledge
there you see the place where you fit a
person inside and from there through
some mechanical sorcery now you would
move the pieces and then the Turk would
beat you and you know they've been
fooling people with the Turk for over 80
years they defeated some very famous
people like Napoleon Bonaparte a
Benjamin Franklin and so on but is there
Ginsberg and when he was 20 years old he
started controlling the Mephisto but it
was a different type of automaton it was
a controlled electronically and also
remotely so there was there wasn't a
person hiding inside of it it was just a
table with a chest and the Mephisto it
was a Red Devil attached to the table
that moved the pieces so I've never
actually seen it work as the whereabouts
of the Mephisto are unknown hour later
Mephisto became a well-known chess chess
playing automaton that that you can buy
even today but yeah and also
interestingly in the the Turk was burned
down in 1854 and also Isadora Ginsberg
was born in 1854 so is there a
coincidence you know hard to say and
yeah a very strong player Capablanca
approaching his prime win
already you know way past his prime
Greene's works almost 25 years before
the 1914 tournament of some pitcher
Pedro Berg in 1891
so 23 years ago faced Williams Chinese
for the title of roaches championship
and he played an excellent match the the
the match was first the first eight wins
or 20 games and then who has the better
score the game ended six to four in
favor of Chinese after 18 games as there
was no more chance for Ginsburg to
actually win the match so Stannis was
awarded the title and declared champion
but a very strong player and here like I
said Kabul uncle some 26 years old
Ginsberg 60 years old it's going to be
quite a game so I do hope you're ready
for it Ginsberg has the white pieces and
he opens with E for we have E 5 by
Capablanca and now like I said Ginsberg
is 60 years old here and he did not just
show up here to be seen he's here to
fight so F for the Kings gambit and as
you all know capablanca it refutes every
gambit and most easily by accepting it
so e captures on f4 and a bunch of the
c4 the so called bishops gambit to the
Kings gambit and trying to get black to
go for this Queen to h4 check which
seems very appealing but of course you
will not play g3 King get 1 and then
white will play d4 then gum comes Knight
to f3 white will use this weird position
of the black Queen to develop the pieces
it was not considered good for black so
after Bishop to c4 cover Blanca
continues developing Knight to f6
attacks d4 pawn Knight to c3 Ginsburg
defends the pawn and now Bishop to b4 a
principle idea attacking the defender of
d4 pawn and here you don't really have
the option of playing d3 to defend it
because d5 will be very strong for black
here why would have to give up the
bishop pair and after Knight captures
still your United threatened it captures
and now even Queen captures as possible
attacking the g2 pawn where black would
be better
so after this Bishop to b4 move we have
E 5 by news Berg and it seems like white
is creating something white hair white
is starting the initiative but black is
actually perfect
we find here of course you will not move
the night even though there are no good
squares for you to actually move the
night you can't go g4 h5 the Queen is
covering those squares then I
discovering these squares you could go
back but that's pretty much pointless d5
by capablanca and now this exchange will
not favour why for example captures
captures and now you could go up we need
to check black block you'll capture here
attack the rook rook g8 and it seems
like white achieved something but not
really black is a much ahead in
development black can just develop the
knight develop the Queen Castle
queenside g7 pawn will be captured and
then black will have a nice semi open G
file for the rook well white still has a
king in the middle of the board and
still has to figure out how to go about
this
so after d5 with Bishop to b3 Bishop e5
check also an option against Burgos for
Bishop to b3 and now comes Knight to e4
and of course you cannot capture here if
you capture the pawn then comes Queen to
h4 check and black wins the game
g3 now comes pawn captures H captures
and now well either you start running
away and lose a lot of material or you
just get checkmated so after 94 we have
Knight to f3 preventing Queen h4 check
and now comes c6 and here Queen to e to
here white prepares the white brothers
to eliminate the d4 Knight the Queen and
Knight threatened to capture and the
Capablanca wants to push g5 so for the
moment it's not possible first he
captures in c3 Bishop captures on c3 now
the the strong knight is stronger than
the bishop we have d captors on c3
opening up blacks
wise dark square bishop and now g5 by
Capablanca we have nice the d2 wanting
to get rid of this night and now push up
to f5 Knight captures with Bishop
captures and here Bishop to b2 now
Ginsburg also has the option of castling
queenside we have Knight to d7 going
after d5 pawn and now C for attacking
Capablanca strong center but also making
room on c3 for the dark square bishop
queenie 7 we have seek after Sundy 5c
captures on d5 and Bishop to c3 and here
it would be too soon to go after the
pawn if you play Knight captures then
you
just run into the spin white can go
Queen b5 check now you can go back with
the night because you lose the rook on
h8 so you'd have to move the king and
it's where do you move the King if you
go King f8 then Bishop b4 wins the Queen
and if you don't if you go something
like King King go over to d8 then you're
just in the center of the board white
will Castle queenside and now your king
is just in the line of in the line of
fire
so after Bishop to c3 we have castles by
capablanca first getting the King to
safety and only now after the castle
link of a Blanca is ready to capture the
pawn but now Ginsberg takes care of it
east six attacks the night and also
there's a discovered attack on the rook
on h8 so to defend both threats we have
Knight to f6 and now comes a captures on
f7 Queen captures and capablanca goes
for Queen side castles and now rook h2e
sorry against bergen's Burgos for
queenside castle and rook h2 e8 so as
you can see it's a Ginsburg who has the
better prepare but capablanca is a bit a
bit ahead in development and there are
no useful discoveries for the moment a
bunch of captures anything will just be
met with Queen captures to whatever
discovery was made and there there are
no other useful discoveries but rip f3
Queen can capture so another problem
Ginsburg goes for h4 with h6h captures H
captures and now rook to h6 a very nice
rock cliff to it that comes with a
double attack
towards the knight on f6 so kappa blanka
defends that we look to e6 defending the
knights twice now but also perhaps the
night this roof can join in the attack
against the white king in some later
point of the game but we have Bishop
captures rook captures on f6 and now not
capturing immediately but first Queen to
g4 check we have looked to a5 blocking
check and also not allowing the roof to
remain a target on f6 and here we have
rook d2 h1 doubling up on the H file
here this was a mistake by Ginsburg a
rook to e1 was a better move but I'll
let you decide why it was a better move
rook to e1 was supposed to be played
against girl played rook to h1 and
before this move still a playable
position
white is doing white is doing rate
Capablanca did not he's up upon but
Ginsburg is throwing a lot of pressure
couple on Cosway here look to each one
was played now feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out why
this doesn't work and why rook to e1
would have been better I will give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
winner of games and for those who who
just won't enjoy the show
rook h1 is a blunder because f3 here and
now you can see that you cannot capture
if you captured and Bishop captures
comes with an attack against the Queen
and against the rook here so it would
not be possible so if we return to this
position before rooks to h1 was played
rook to e1 is better now you're already
threatening rook captures only for the
points pinned due to the bishop being on
f3 and also now f3 doesn't really do
anything you can just capture it and the
characters only comes with an attack
against the Queen 24 there are no hidden
dangers here but ok look to each one of
us played congratulations if you found
the refutation f3 pins were played h7
rook - h7 attacking cover Blancas queen
and now once again I ask you to pause
the video and try to find the end of
this game for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent temporary sacrificer of Queens
and for those who just want to show F
KERS on g2 was played a very temporary
Queen sacrifice by Capablanca
and now if you capture on f7 you get 10
G captures on h1 you can bring a queen
into the game and now after you move the
King or the Queen moves you can just
capture capture and in the end you will
be up a whole rook so after this F
captures and g2 agains were played rook
1 to h6
and here kappa blanka just played pawn
to g1 and he bring he brought up another
queen into the game even though he could
have brought a rock into the game which
check doesn't even doesn't really matter
it would still be winning for him but
Capablanca does not fool around when
it's you know when it's time to play
chess so it was in this position and
move 26 that Ginsburg resigned the game
because after Queen captures just look
at one wins the Queen and it's all
captures captures and now white is soon
getting checkmate it if you go down here
is rebuttal f3 check or queen to yun
checkmate so you'd have to go up the
board king c 3 and then a 5 d 4 is
coming the white king will be checkmated
fairly soon
yeah after this move work up a Blanca
brought another queen into the game
Isadora Ginsburg resigned the game and
yet another victory for Jose Roca Blanco
who is still the sole leader in this
tournament
next game we have the last game of the
first part of the 1914 tournament in San
Pittsburgh so we're gonna have the
standings after the first part before we
go into the double round-robin where
five players will just brawl it out so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you are enjoying my
coverage of the Capablanca saga so far I
would like to thank Anton baklanov a
Weasley Santos joseph compression in
Karel Podolski Anthony Villalpando for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content Lia and stockfish are or I
believe almost over would their match so
we're gonna perhaps visit that and next
game I believe it's horrible kappa
blanka vs. the black death you Joseph
Henry Blackburn so that should that
should be a treat
thank you all and I'll see you soon have
an excellent rest of your Friday